welcome back to new rockstars the
avengers will assemble
in some crossover crisis on the horizon
but what will it be
mutants a battle royale a squirrel
search for nick fury's shoes
we need answers but i guess we'll settle
for theories
i'm eric boss this is rogue theory the
show that brings you the wildest
nerdy hot takes on the topics you can't
stop arguing about with me today
is an all-star panel i'm so excited
by our guests today we got our friend
and host of correct mundo on el rey
network and many other things
hector navarro hello hello hi hello
welcome back
and uh friend of the show comedian and
writer jessica clemons
hi hi and we are so thrilled to welcome
for the first time on rogue
first time on new rockstars i think you
know him from schmodown many many other
great geeky stuff online he's the host
of the all my movies podcast and youtube
show which drops every wednesday welcome
to new rockstars
dan merle hello it's someone i'm glad to
be here this is gonna be a lot of fun i
can't wait
yeah yeah i'm so excited uh we are at an
interesting crossroads here at the dawn
of marvel phase four with one division
coming soon in the past the avengers
have been drawn together by loki's
attack on earth by ultron by a civil war
event
and of course by uh thanos and infinity
war and endgame but we know
another crossover is coming see when uh
sony and marvel signed that deal to
share um custody of tom holland last
year the specifics of the deal was that
it was going to be for two more films at
least so we have spider-man 3 which
we've been learning so so much about
in recent weeks but then there was also
another
mystery mcu crossover event and
since then we have gotten some hints
that that crossover could go
in a few different directions a
multiverse a house of m
kind of thing maybe a secret invasion
kind of thing there's just a lot of
potential crises on the road ahead that
could all be avengers level threats so
i want each of you to pitch me your
theories and predictions for
that next avengers level crossover
crisis
that marvel is building up to hector why
don't you go first
i will gladly go first i know the new
rock stars is all about that multiversal
spider-man 3 thing and
i am not on that train dude i happen to
disagree with that i think
that a doctor strange cameo doesn't
necessarily mean
multiverse i mean he showed up in the
thor movie and he was just doing doctor
strange stuff
i also think that bringing back jamie
foxx doesn't necessarily mean
we're gonna get a multiverse electro
popping in from another dimension i
think it's just gonna be
hey we liked jamie foxx the first time
let's let's let him do it again
uh similar to jk simmons being j jonah
jameson again and that jay jonah
is not necessarily and i don't think
they're gonna reveal that that dude is
from another dimension because i feel
like that would be a bigger news story
than him being like sit down folks i'm
gonna tell you about spider-man he'd be
like it's me j jonah jameson from
another universe remember and i'm trying
to find my way home like
i just i feel that spider-man 3 may have
to do with some scrolls
because of the fact that spidey's
identity was revealed to the public by
jay jonah
i think that the end ts of spider-man
far from home where they revealed that
that nick fury and maria hill were
scrolls the whole time
wasn't just like hey remember scrolls
yeah we're setting up captain marvel
stuff i feel like they're going to play
into that in spite e3
that that might be the way that peter
can somehow prove that he's not
spider-man
by having a scroll help him out and
shape-shift and be like look i'm peter
parker and there's spider-man that kind
of a thing that happens all the time in
comic books when like you know superman
asks batman
or batman asks superman to dress up as
batman and bruce wayne's like look
there's bat i'm not batman there he is
see if he's over there i can't also be
here it happens all the time but i think
eventually that will lead to
i feel like the geniuses over at marvel
are not going to let this marketing
opportunity slip through their fingers
it's secret invasion all the way because
there's no better marketing
thing in comics of the past 20 years
than who do you trust
secret invasion and that's what the
comic books we're leaning into who do
you trust who do you trust
and the fans were speculating who's a
scroll oh my gosh oh my god i can't i
can't wait to see
read this comic and figure out what the
what they're going to reveal i think
they're going to do that in the movies
the same way that civil war captain
america civil war was like whose side
are you on that's lifted straight from
marvel comics in 2006
that's just already marketing that they
know is gonna be catchy and
and you know grabbable so i believe that
the next time we see the avengers
in an avengers movie or something other
is going to be a big
whoa everybody let's get together
because there have been scrolls this
whole time are they good are they bad
who's been a scroll which of us have
been a scroll michael douglas is this
girl oh my gosh like
you know like that kind of thing is
going to be something that i think is is
too tempting for them not to play with
so to sum up secret invasion leaning
into the scroll shape-shifting
that's uh that's an interesting take and
uh kudos to you hector for
kind of unblowing our minds and then
re-blowing it in another way
because yeah you are right here at new
rockstars we're like uh the moment we
see a character
from a different in our mind cinematic
universe crossing over we're just going
to jump to that conclusion
i appreciate it it's very good work and
i appreciate that i just happen to think
it may be a little too far sometimes
there you know what you're doing eric
you know
it's fair it's a fair point and it's
it's a bold brave point you're coming in
here and you're you're
pointing out you know what we're we're
already seeing through walls but there
are walls there and we should
acknowledge them
and i will say coming out of spiderman
far from a move you were to ask me what
the next step was i'm gonna be like yeah
a secret invasion is happening
the fact that like you're just revealing
nick fear to be a scroll that's uh the
last mc movie we saw
that seemed to be what it was it was
setting up and you know with the fury
series happening on disney plus yeah i i
could absolutely
see that being the case so excellent
excellent theory hector i
absolutely think secret invasion is on
horizon and for that you're gonna get
three points man
great just writing
great okay all right um jessica it is
your turn i want to hear from you what
do you think the big uh
avengers level crisis crossover that
they're building up to is going to be
so i do really like hector's take i will
say that i'll even like dan's take
but i think my take superior and let me
tell you why it's superior
because i love chaos i'm a crazy person
we love crazy things and that's why i
think the next avengers movies we're
going to see is
going to be secret wars because secret
wars
would be so much fun we are seeing we're
getting to a point
yeah i know we're getting to a point
where we can't even keep track
of how many mcu characters there are we
are like oh we know but then we also
like since san diego comic con they
revealed all these other shows that
they're doing with so many more
characters
and now that we're getting into like
eternals it's like okay now we have
more gods to keep track of so i think
we're getting to a point where it's like
okay
how can we top that fight that we saw in
end game
yes we had everybody in there but like
we still are learning more about
monica we haven't even seen deadpool we
haven't seen
like another doom in a minute what are
we gonna do and it's like why don't we
get beyond her in here
and just have them all go at it on
battle world and i
know that there was so i read the 2015
comic issue
on the comic of uh secret world or six
our
secret world i said battle world and
secret wars at the same time
i read the doom one and i love the doom
one i think it's really underrated
but then i looked into the 1980s one and
i was like why don't we just combine the
two
because you know how marvel can't do
like they can try to align with the
comic books but for continuity they're
like we have to like
do our own little spin on it so why
don't we have like a two-parter
or just like a five-hour long movie
where doom becomes the like leader of it
all
and then we don't even get beyond her
anymore like beyond her somehow falls
to dooms like over leadership um because
there's
sorry i'm going on for so long i just
love seeing i think it's really fun
because we're also being revealed like
the in like internalize how these
superheroes feel
and how they have to struggle with their
own identity while they're on a planet
fighting themselves basically so i think
we should see
doom becoming the leader of everything
and them just being like
i don't know who to follow and a bunch
of chaos ensues and that is
phase five of avengers sign me up
here's my money for the ticket give me a
producer credit
right now yeah remember this remember
this pitch
for sure jessica yeah you are right and
the russos have even said this that like
the only
crossover moment they could conceive
that would top end game would be
something like secret wars
and like yeah it is kind of like a
childish notion
in a great way of like what do we all
love about these characters what if we
could just throw them all in a toy box
and have our action figures fight each
other and they would normally
never hang out that's what battle world
is and that's why it's so great
but like your choice to have doom be the
mastermind of it i think it's great
i mean nothing against the beyonder i
just thought he was more interesting
when he was like a voice from the cosmos
as opposed to what he was later revealed
to me which is like if i remember
correctly in 80s like
white jacket yeah cool guy you know like
that was kind of
it could be fun if you would imagine
like james gunn or
or taika with tt um their spin on that
but ultimately i can imagine doom being
like the mastermind pulling the strings
of all these people to
to work themselves against each other in
some kind of multiversal way
yeah i i love that idea so jessica i'm
going to award you the same
number of points i gave hector three
points
these are two pens i'm excited
this is me clapping because john told me
not to be so loud on camera
all right dan it's your turn what do you
think is going to be this big crossover
event that uh they're all working toward
i was not aware there were points on the
line until just now so i'm going to be
much more competitive
but here's what i'll say this is this
may be more of a theory than a
prediction
but we're talking about spider-man here
really we're rooted in spider-man that's
what everybody's talking about
what defines spider-man science
right and being haunted by people
that he has failed to protect in the
past these are two definitive things
about spider-man
where do science and ghosts merge
marvel zombies that's where science and
ghosts
come together the ultimate failure of
science
uh the dead literally rising from the
grave uh but it's not just a joke
because
we're we're we're talking about this
multiverse
infinite possibilities infinite pod you
can go anywhere so we see peter thrown
into this
chaos where uh first of all you can
bring back
anybody anybody you could bring but you
could bring back robert downey jr if you
wanted to you could bring back
you can bring back chris evans and they
don't have to worry about signing a
multi-film contract or whatever because
you're off in your little pocket
universe
but you can bring back all the ghosts
from peter's past to haunt them that you
want
it's different we have we have the roots
and we have so many people with roots in
horror that are part of the cinematic
marvel cinematic universe or have been
james gunn and scott derrickson
and you have doctor strange perhaps this
can continue on we're going into this
multiverse of madness
zombies are madness i've never heard of
anything what's more bad than a world
full of zombies
i think you have the potential to kind
of start this with peter
and then roll this out over you know i
don't think it's going to be like an
infiniti saga number of movies but two
or three movies
um kind of this little mini horror arc
and you need to keep things fresh
you got to keep things fresh in the mcu
and they haven't really leaned into the
horror direction too much and actually
my favorite part
of spider-man far from home was that
kind of
horror-esque segment with mysterio where
like peter's being haunted by nightmares
like that was so cool that was so
awesome
so i think you throw them into this
weird alternate universe
you can bring back whoever you want and
as a bonus
if they so desire if you're going back
to marvel zombies
some key figures in that whole event the
fantastic four
maybe like freddy krueger you pull them
back from whatever alternate dimension
that you've gone to
and now you have uh your fantastic four
in your marvel universe
i i totally agree man i think the mcu is
ready for
marvel zombies and like if you were to
ask me like five years ago i'd be like
nah it's too
it's too different but you're totally
right after that sequence and far from
home
that was like one of my favorite
sequences i remember seeing in a theater
like to me that was like as enjoyable to
watch as anything in endgame
just like whoa there i i've never seen
the marvel cinematic universe do this
kind of imagery before
the spider crawling out of the iron man
helmet as it claws out of the grave like
to me i don't know if that was an
intentional setup of a marvel zombies
thing but like
it should be because that i i do want to
live in that movie and just see where
that goes of
not just an illusion but like i want to
see what happens
where peter's being terrified and yeah
maybe that's what they were going with
by having sam raimi come direct the next
uh
uh doctor strange movie right like that
guy has plenty of experience with uh you
know
reanimated corpses coming back for the
grave whether it's evil dead or dragged
me to hell or whatever it is you know so
yeah uh for that i'm gonna you know i i
was equally smitten
with all three theories so you're
getting uh the power of three by three
uh you're getting another three points
i'll take them these points
what game is this what is this game
what is this madness what is this
multiverse of madness
uh guys all three of these theories were
were fantastic i mean
i i'm kind of torn between which one i
want to see
first i hope that we see them all at
some point because here's the deal
every time we come here on the rogue
theory we always mention like is this a
theory too rogue or is this too much a
fan service it's like
look all these studios you know kevin
feige's like i don't know how long
fans are gonna be into superhero movies
we're gonna take like the biggest
crossover titles that we
can and work them into a movie in the
next decade some way or another
why wait you know why do you think
before writing the scripts that they go
on
like well they probably do they go
online and look at fan theories and
they're just like oh that's a good idea
yes i assume that they are watching this
video
right now we're taking notes and they're
like
we're gonna bring iron man back as a
zombie and he's gonna shoot his lasers
and he's gonna murder everyone if you've
ever talked about marvel movies on the
internet
i believe that disney owes you five
million dollars
yes guys we're gonna get a class action
lawsuit started we're gonna
get our money we're gonna get paid and
then uh
yeah that's that's how the world works
true kevin feige's watching right now
i'm sure new rockstars is probably a
very
heavily visited youtube page that kevin
feige visits so hi kevin just want to
say hi
hi kevin please nova please give us a
latino superhero thanks
adopt me adopt me so i can write a story
for you
it won't be good but i'm i'm there i'm
all right come on think about it all
right uh we're gonna move on to some
theories about uh the mandalorian season
two which is imminent but before we do
we want to thank some friends who helped
us make this episode
first our friends at manscaped listen up
fellas because today we have a new
manscape product alert
manscaped to just release the weed
whacker nose and
ear hair trimmer and it's time to keep
your nose and your hair looking
as the other clean shaven parts of your
body do
and feeling fresh so fresh and so clean
and so smooth
and so beautiful um i have already
opened this but it resealed which is
scaring me because it's like how did it
reseal that's a special feature that's
that's just it seals itself to keep
itself clean and fresh
all right so this is what it looks like
it's just a simple unassuming thing that
can just sneak on up into your orifices
and you never knew it was there
oh oh of freezing i uh look i love john
carpenter's the thing it's one of my
favorite movies i'm watching it right
now it's halloween season
i thought wilford brimley was great in
that movie but my dude could have used
some help in the nose hair department
and other people agree actually 79 of
partners folds said that long
nose hair is a major turn off it didn't
it didn't spoil wilfred brimley for me
uh i i
contract diabetes any day of the week to
spend a night with him
that's how it passes right uh i'm not
gonna pull those bad boys out of my nose
by hand
life is painful enough already manscaped
is here to save you it's forever
changing the grooming game with their
weed whacker this nose and ear hair
trimmer provides proprietary skin safe
technology
which helps prevent nicks snags and tugs
and those delicate nostrils that's gross
that i'm doing this on camera but i'm
just demonstrating hey it shouldn't feel
bad about it it feels actually real good
the manscaped weed wacker uses a 9 000
rpm 360 degree rotary dual blade system
with a contoured design to enhance the
trimming experience it's waterproof so
it's easy to use and clean
and it has a rechargeable battery that
lasts up to 90 minutes
in case you know you have a giant nose
and a lot of hair in it
it's time to upgrade your manscape
routine with the weed whacker
get 20 off and free shipping with the
code rogue theory at manscape.com
that's 20 off with free shipping at
manscape.com
and use the code rogue theory what are
you waiting for go whack your weeds my
friends
go whack your weave whack your wings
weeds it's just the gardener's version
of home makeover
it comes with your own audience all
right we also want to thank our friends
at expressvpn
i recently watched that movie the social
dilemma on netflix so you guys see that
documentary
oh boy um well we learned in this movie
tech insiders explained to you how
social media is basically engineered to
exploit users data for profit
they call it surveillance capitalism i
don't want my data being harvested so
tech billionaires can get even richer
and richer i get
nothing out of it that's why i put a
layer of protection around my data with
expressvpn every time you use the
internet big tech companies mind your
data by tracking your searches
messages video history but when you run
expressvpn on your device it hides your
ip address which websites can use to
personally identify you
this vpn makes your activity more
difficult to trace and sell to
advertisers now you still got to be
careful with what you share on social
media of course but
expressvpn can make your web browsing
more anonymous
expressvp and also encrypts 100 of your
internet data to keep you safe from
hackers and all
kinds of prying eyes many vpns slow down
your internet but
expressvpn it is incredibly fast and
easy to use
just tap one button you are protected
i don't want to gross too out but i
think a nose hair just would
oh my god this is awful um i'm gonna be
coughing up hairballs halfway through
this episode
so if you don't like the idea of tech
companies exploiting your personal
information then visit expressvpn.com
rogue right now and you can get three
extra months of expressvpn for free that
is e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn dot com slash rogue
to protect your data
go to expressvpn.comrogue to learn more
and uh before we continue quick shout
out to our patron
sassy bobby who won this week's discord
rogue theory with an awesome pitch
for how miles morales could show up in
the mcu as a classmate and a love
interest
of kate bishop and the hawkeye disney
plus series that i think is still
happening
someday to pitch your own mcu teen
romance become a patron by going to
patreon.com
new rockstars so uh let's move on to our
second topic
uh socatano who did not show up in the
recent mandalorian trailer but will
probably show up at some point this
season
of the mandalorian season two we got
what might turn out to be the final
trailer
ahead of its october 30th debut during
monday night football this week
and yeah while we got more of that hot
hot grief karga action we all love
one announced character of season two
has been conspicuously absent from many
other trailers
our beloved clone wars and rebels rebel
ahsoka tano
uh of course can be played by rosario
dawson how do you guys think ahsoka tano
is going to join this show from where we
last saw her in rebels and i guess
in the prequel series the clone wars and
what do you think she's going to want
from baby yoda in season
two and dan why don't we start with you
this time well i think
what i hope is is going to happen is
that what i loved about mandalorian
season one was that there was a
there was a light over arcing storyline
but each episode was also kind of its
own adventure
yeah there were there you had you open
and closed a loop
in just about every single episode and
so i know that fans are clamoring for
sokkatano
they want her i i don't necessarily
think she should be in every episode or
maybe even
several episodes i think she's a
character that could come in and out
of the show but i think as as
mando and the child slash baby yoda it's
like mean girls stop trying to make the
child happen the child is not happening
babies
are flying around the galaxy i like that
i like the name of the child but
everyone's everyone says baby yeah but
they they're always and they're always
in some scrapes they always need some
help and as we've seen
the child has shown some obvious force
abilities
uh some major force action going on
ahsoka tano is gonna pick that up
she is a force user there's not a whole
lot of them out in the galaxy
so i think that they are going to be in
a situation where they need some help
perhaps the child is at a very critical
point
perhaps mando isn't really sure what to
do at this point because he doesn't
understand these powers
he certainly has heard of them but he
doesn't understand them i'd love to see
ahsoka
tunnel come in be kind of a mentor role
a bit of a
co-badass with uh with the mandalorian
and i think her overarching structure
and where i think
you could start drawing some lines to
other parts of the star wars universe
i think the reason that she's out in the
galaxy
is that she herself is embarking upon
the journey
that luke skywalker would later uh would
later
take part in himself uh where you know
she's had a bit of a rocky road with the
jedi order she obviously saw
the fall of the jedi her mentor was the
was the biggest
even though he was redeemed the scourge
of the galaxy
so she's gonna have some very difficult
feelings towards the force perhaps go
back to the origins of the force
so i believe that she will be in search
of
the first jedi temple much like luke
skywalker was
when we opened the force awakens and i
will go even further to say that we are
going to solve a mystery from the force
awakens
that like the other mysteries were all
dropped in the subsequent
movies that the grave that we
see luke skywalker standing in front of
in the force awakens when rey arrives on
acto or act two or however you pronounce
it
is ahsoka tanos because she was there
when luke
arrived and they perhaps spin spin-off
potential
perhaps they spent some time together uh
learning the ways of the force
man dan that is an awesome theory i love
that idea because yeah we've never seen
these two characters together but
obviously their destinies are
uh you know connected at least like well
we had that closing shot of the clone
wars where vader was
at what he might have thought was her
grave or at least the grave of her clone
troopers
looks up sees the bird uh and it's just
a powerful moment
to go back and connect that to vader's
son
would be freaking dope i would love to
see that that's such a cool idea
uh so that would that would rhyme yeah
like poetry yeah like poetry
jar jar is the key to all of it you know
that would be beautiful beautiful poetry
for that poetry for ending uh that
couplet ryman my friend
you are gonna get uh four points damn no
one's ever gotten
four points we got four points all right
uh jessica let's see if you can top it
what is your theory for
ahsoka tano in mandalorian season two
you're like
damn i love that then you're gonna
remind me like jessica get out
[Laughter]
see yourself out now i'll start by
saying what you can edit out
i like star wars
[Laughter]
i like the star wars i love the space
fights who doesn't
i will say i i i it doesn't stick to me
i'm not like a sponge with star wars
like i am with marvel and dc
and like harry potter and other weird
twilight
uh other weird nerdy realms so i called
my mom about this because my mom likes
star wars because she watches with my
nephew all the time
and after she scolded me for
not really watching the rebels she was
helping me figure out that like what i
ultimately think
that sabine and her are doing
in the mandalorian too are looking for
the dark saber
so sure we don't we always know is that
moth gideon has it we don't know what
happened
correct me if i'm wrong i like them on
rogue theory like someone tell me if i'm
right
we don't know what really happened after
darth maul had it correct
well it just gave us some timeline
there's some huge gaps in the timeline
right like maul did have it
uh he was defeated in this final season
of clone wars and then chronologically
bo katan has it at the end of rebels but
we don't know what happened at that
point until moff gideon has it yeah
my mom also suggested this is a if i get
points is going to my mom
my mom suggested that the mob gideon
killed
katan and then took the sword and then
that's what she thinks and then we were
like oh okay so that would make sense
why we see
later on rosaria dawson the mandalorian
two
i think that i don't think she the goal
is like i think she's also just gonna be
in like an episode
i think she's gonna have like a big
episode um i don't think she's gonna be
the main cast member or like the main
like she's gonna
align and stay there forever i also
think that they unintentionally
will cross paths and that's when they're
like i agree with dan where they're
gonna be like oh can you help
teach this kid because i don't know this
child um because i don't know how
and so i think that she gets together
with sabine
and while she's looking for the dark
saber with the force of beans there to
also ultimately get the dark saber back
from off gideon and i think she's
because like we last time we saw her was
with the inquisitors just killing
everyone so i still think she's trying
to ultimately
keep that bad power out of bad hands
which maf gideon obviously is not a good
person
so i think that she's just looking for
the dark saber
and that's why we got that little end
piece and that's what's gonna happen and
we're only gonna see it for an episode
uh i think that's totally um spot on
like you wouldn't have had to proceed
your theory with
you not knowing too much about rebels
because you you sound pretty expertise
for helping me out with that but i think
the dark saber is uh
anyone who walked out of that closing
shot of mandalorian season one
might have seen some kind of connection
oh well with rosario dawson coming in
she's uh you know one of the few
ex-jedi exist in this universe we might
see some kind of lightsaber action with
her and and mop gideon who i don't think
is a jedi
might be someone who's just like
obsessed with uh jedi relics or things
like that
but yeah i absolutely could see that as
a plausible theory um
jessica for that i'm gonna give you uh
three points oh my god
my mom she's gonna be so happy also
sidebar really quick
is it confirmed that sasha banks is
actually playing sabine or we just know
that she's in it
we know that sasha banks is in it um
just we saw her face in the trailer we
don't know if she's playing sabine
yet i think another thing has even been
confirmed that rosario dawson is playing
this song
is that even confirmed i don't think
it's confirmed uh
yeah i mean you know star wars lucasfilm
they're not gonna outright confirm
anything
yet but by the the sources we trust the
trades seem to be pretty convinced
that's who she's playing
i read about it it also said that she
accidentally like leaked it herself on
like
instagram and deleted the posts so i
think
it might be true that's the most
verified source i could find is uh
accidentally outing herself um i love
rosaria dawson also so it's like
whatever she wants to do i'm on board
absolutely all right uh hector it's your
turn how do you think ahsoka is going to
join this mandalorian show first of all
i'm going to agree with everybody else
and say she's only going to be in one
episode all right we got that out of the
way she's only in one episode that's the
way to do it don't make the whole show
about her
it's about baby yoda secondly the end of
season one
we had a character death and it was
pretty epic
it was in the last episode which was
directed by taika waititi taika's
character that he played himself ig-11
who we only like re fell in love with in
the last episode or two because they
reintroduced him and they're like
now he's a nanny now he will take care
of the baby and we're like
oh because he was only in the first
episode and then he died i think a lot
of that love of that character comes
from just our residual love of taika
waititi himself is not necessarily a
beloved character but when he i know
when he exploded i was like
taiga like i didn't care about ig-11 but
it was a great it was a great epic
moment
how do you top that i'm going hard
left i'm going rogue baby all right i'm
getting mean
with this you know who works on
mandalorian dave filoni
you know what other show he worked on
the clone wars show that created the
character of ahsoka tano you know what i
think
i think creators love to create a
character and kill the character
i think we're getting the end of ahsoka
tano's
life on this plane and then she'll
become a force ghost i think she's gonna
end up in the last episode
i think she's gonna show up when mando
has finally gotten to a point where he's
like i need to find
a jedi or an ex-jedi or somebody who can
tell me where i can take this child
where i can take this baby yoda
and she'll show up and she's like yeah i
can help you but there's going to be
this big epic
sacrificial moment she's going to go out
and it's going to make us all cry and
it's going to be crazy and then
afterwards
she's going to be able to force ghost
contact yoda and yoda will be like
you're getting a yoda cameo and he will
be like oh
baby and then he'll provide the
information that amanda will be like
cool we'll see you in season three and
then we'll go from there but i think
that dave filoni
and the gang are going to be too tempted
to
give an epic death to a beloved
star wars franchise character which we
have seen so many epic deaths and so
many beautiful moments and so many
beginnings and endings to so many great
characters why not give a great
storyline behind the reasoning for why
an elderly ahsoka tano wasn't in the
sequel movies why she doesn't show up
and help rey why should
you know the star wars timeline loves to
do that it loves to explain
why character why why wasn't diego luna
and you hope they all died at the end of
rogue one so i think we're gonna get a
similar
kind of an epic send-off for the
character that's what i think
yeah and you know oh my god i'm so
choked up
with my own nose here yeah hector you
bring up a good point because there is
some debate about ahsoka tano she did
show up as like a
force ghost voice during that ghost of
jedi past and in the rise of skywalker
which it was the
i think was the animated series voice
because before rosario dawson
was uh rumored or announced but like a
lot of people were saying was like oh
she's a force ghost does that mean she
is now dead in the future uh and then
dave filoni kind of went back and forth
on it so we're not really sure
what her fate is this would be an
awesome way to explain how
she uh got to her astral form look i
wouldn't be too bummed to see uh ahsoka
die just because we saw her whole life
story
in the clone wars we don't need an
entire
other series or we continue to follow
this character again and again for years
and years
so if they did kill her off i wouldn't
be too bummed especially if they did in
a really cool way
it's not something that i think back in
the day years ago if you had killed off
a prominent female character in a big
franchise with visibility like this
people would understandably be like hey
that sucks don't do that there's not
enough female
but the good news is is that since 2015
star wars as a brand has kind of
become more diverse there's definitely
more female characters other than
princess leia
which is great uh there's a bunch of you
know characters that represent
all types of different people and fans
of star wars and the cool thing is is
that
again even since 2015 with sort of
restructuring everything
they've really embraced what happened
before with the expanded universe and
the novels and comics and everything
disney took that idea and was like that
stuff got so wackadoo crazy
we love that idea let's still publish
that stuff and fans can still read it
but let's really embrace that meaning
if we have a novel come out it's canon a
comic book that comes out it's canon and
you can still tell those kinds of
stories with ahsoka you can have books
and she's already
she's already been the star of books you
know she's she she can appear in comic
books so
just because a character dies on screen
doesn't necessarily mean you can't go
back and look diego luna is getting a
disney plush show like kenobi is getting
a story exactly like a
super duper series and another series it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter so yeah
can i endorse hectors just because i
want to know more about yoda's
reaction when they contacted them
there must be no didn't tell me yeah
that's right yeah baby episode one
phantom menace ever heard of it
yeah yeah yeah she's the female yoda
yes she didn't come back and attack of
the clones it's because it was like a
peggy olsen storyline
she just went off somewhere that's what
they do in the jedi order it's it's a
weird
weird system weird system well uh hector
you're gonna get three points for your
theory i love your theories
all right uh it's still pretty even
though i believe it's 766
but we're gonna see where we're at at
the end of our rogue
question we just got one question this
week uh our man liam neeson
was number one at the box office over
the weekend
if the box office still even counts what
office sure it does
it does there's an office somewhere full
of boxes
uh it's in a box within another box with
another box so you gotta find
you gotta find it but his movie is
called an honest thief and it was
reigning champion
at the box office so uh in honor of our
geriatric irish action hero who just
gets stronger and stronger as he ages
i would like each of you to give me what
your
very particular set of skills speech
might sound like
if you had to give it to someone in
2020.
anybody can go first i'll do it
sure go for it i'm going to try to do my
best liam neeson
which means it's going to be terrible
but this is very much centered on my
life for the last seven months
seven years i don't know anyway you have
to imagine i'm on the phone with
somebody um
i don't know who you are i don't know
what you want
i don't know what day it is i don't know
if i'm wearing pants
but if you're looking for toilet paper i
can tell you i don't have any
or paper towels it's very messy here
what i do have a very particular set of
skills
skills that i've acquired since around
march 7th
skills that were useless until this year
if you leave my instacart order on the
door and leave now that'll be the end of
it
but if you ring the doorbell i will make
eye contact
i will make awkward small talk i will do
that awkward elbow handshake thing
and i will make it awkward
yeah oh i got chills
i can go next also i feel like next time
whoever goes first should always just
get an extra point for going first
because i definitely
i avoid it i'm like someone else go
first i'm not going to do an alien news
voice because i cannot
but oh i can't either but i i you're
probably making the better choice
um i don't know who you are i don't know
what you want
if it's money i can tell you that i'm
unemployed
because it's 20 20. and we all have lost
our jobs
if you want hand sanitizer we don't have
any we've been making it our own
you can try bleach like our president
said to but i
i wouldn't you're probably sitting there
and you're wondering
what kind of world are you living in and
i'll tell you that it's
america 2020 and i am lost
my car is just broken because i haven't
driven it in months
but honestly i might have to move back
home to my mother's house
like everybody else and uh that's what i
tell someone that's what i um
can you tell that i'm not doing well no
it won't it's very happy
well we can we're very worried and it
sounds like liam neeson has just started
to trail off a little bit he's not that
threatening anymore he's not
we are worried about him he's truly
eating
saltine crackers and orange juice every
day
the most menacing that liam neeson was
was 10 seconds
before they called cut on that one scene
and taken and it's been downhill from
there
that's true all right hector that last
one jessica that was too real that was
too real
i literally looked into a mirror and i
just talked to myself
that's what you get okay listen
carefully
because i've got a very particular set
of skills
i'm an american citizen
i will work for the fbi and here are my
set of skills
i can watch every blu-ray that i own but
not only that
every special feature every commentary
track every deleted scene
and not only that i can read every
tie-in comic book
and movie novelization this particular
set of skills has made me perfectly
suited for quarantine because i can make
the hours pass as if they were
minutes i can spend the entirety of
months
going on years going through every
season of the simpsons
i'm only on season five i've got 26 more
to go
[Laughter]
and why is everyone watching the
simpsons
literally everyone else yeah
disney plus has made it too easy to
watch all three decades of the simpsons
but not just disney plus
the dvds because of that one episode
unfortunately with michael jackson it's
not on disney plus it's on the dvd and
i've seen it
i've done it in my marathon that's how
skilled i am at this
liam liam did they take the 911 episode
off of disney plus two i haven't gotten
there yet i don't
know i think yeah
okay i will report back when i get there
in four months
and you're problematic for still
watching the michael jackson i know
i know i'm problematic for a lot of
other reasons too
the very least of watching the michael
jackson simpsons episode with leon
kampowski yes you're right
[Laughter]
all right all three calls did take me
places um
hector i'm going to award you one uh
point because yes
we you kept going we had a follow-up
round and he stayed in character very
sharp
very good uh but dan i'm also going to
award you a point
just because i you painted a beautiful
picture of that doorway communication
the eye contact i felt it i was there uh
which makes dan
you the winner of this episode of rogue
theory congratulations
i do i didn't have it i don't have
anything prepared thank you
that's incredible that's that's totally
fine but that uh does it for this week's
episode
excellent job we had some amazing
theories both rounds i'm very excited
hopefully one of us is right hopefully
kevin is watching at home
and he's going to take one of these and
we're getting into the storyline
it's your daughter
[Laughter]
is kathleen kennedy with you hi kathy
yeah hey kathy kathy and cabbie
hanging out watching new rock stars
shout out to sarah finn casting director
make sure she gets a raise every year hi
sarah yes
hi yeah the true hero of uh of the mcu
absolutely oh yeah well thank you to all
of our guests uh be sure
to uh follow uh dan merle at all my
movies
subscribe to that uh it's amazing uh
follow jessica clements
at all the stuff she's working on
jessica do you have any particular
projects do a shout out um
uh nope just just a couple parts just
got fired it's a couple twos
uh and then uh hector navarro of course
host of correct mundo
thank you for coming back on the show
hector and for all of you watching don't
forget to subscribe to the rogue theory
podcast feed stay tuned
to this youtube channel for this and
other shows follow me at eavos follow
new rockstars and social medias we'll
see you next week bye everybody thanks
[Music]
you
[Music]